the idea that there is an inevitable
trajectory towards complex life and
perhaps towards something like humans
is a little bit wishful thinking
the origin of complex cells happened
just once on earth
if we think about other planets
the likelihood is elsewhere we'll find
bacteria
and this idea that
we are somehow more evolved than
bacteria is not really true
i work on the deep history of life the
origin of life through to the evolution
of early cells and what that means for
us today
why do we age why do we get diseases why
are we conscious has there been long
gaps two or three billion years where
it's just bacteria and nothing else and
you can't explain that just in terms of
genes
we wouldn't know anything about what
happened in the first two billion years
of life on earth if it hadn't been for
gene sequencing but life is not only
about information it's about the
structure of cells it's about the
turnover of molecules how gases in the
environment are converted into more
molecules none of this has anything to
do with genes all of this happens
spontaneously
i think my work's important because it's
asking some of the biggest questions in
science
what i'm doing is putting back a side
that's been missing for a long time
which is energy flow and its importance
and how that changes the way that
evolution happens
the strange thing is very few people in
the world are thinking along those lines
and it has an ability to come up with an
almost alternative view of the whole
history of life
[Music]
if i say origin of life to you virtually
everybody will say primordial soup
i think the idea of the primordial soup
is a is a terrible idea it just won't go
away and the thing about life is it has
structure it has movement it's a
continuous chemical reaction and the
problem with any kind of soup is it's
basically it's not reactive it doesn't
have the flow of energy going through it
and so i think it's a really bad way of
seeing the origin of life and i much
prefer to think about what are cells
doing and what's the simplest version of
how do cells become animated and are
there geological environments that work
that way and the answer is yes there are
i think life started down in the deep
oceans in hydrothermal vents
but the earth was very different
four billion years ago because there was
no oxygen back then
and if you're working on the origin of
life which i do
then you're starting with really simple
prebiotic chemistry we're trying to do
it under strictly anoxic conditions so
in the strict absence of oxygen
but the questions are really very simple
questions about how can we have the
simplest possible version of a
hydrothermal vent in a lab so we use in
a sense as little technology as we can
get away with
[Music]
nobody can agree about what complex life
actually means what i mean is the
difference between bacteria and the kind
of cells that make up animals and plants
and single celled organisms that eat
other things
our kind of cell is called the
eukaryotic cell which just means it's
got a nucleus and the dna is packaged
away in the nucleus
they're a lot bigger a lot more complex
than bacteria
all these complex cells in plants in
animals in fungi they all have basically
the same structure
our kind of cell arose once in four
billion years of evolution and it seems
to have been something of
a bit of a freak accident
for 2 billion years we have just
bacteria and the bacteria remain as
bacteria
then we have an abrupt single origin of
all complex cells that happens around 2
billion years ago
and then we have another long period of
stasis until the cambrian explosion
where suddenly animals appear
nearly 100 million years after that
before we get plants on land
hundreds of millions of years longer and
then we're beginning to see humans
evolving and consciousness as we would
recognize
what explains these long gaps
what kind of evolutionary process gives
rise to two types of life that live in
completely different ways
perhaps it's nothing to do with genes
and information perhaps it's something
to do with the cell structure
so we have these mitochondria which were
bacteria once
and they seemed to have arisen around
two billion years ago
and the answer is almost certainly that
another cell got inside
and that changes the topology it changes
the way that energy works in cells
now it's internalized and that means you
can expand you can do different things
it opens up the floodgates to evolution
[Music]
we are a continuous chemical reaction we
are continually burning food in oxygen
life has a very central logic which is
to do with growth
growth is really just doubling is
converting whatever's in the environment
into more of yourself
and we've got a circulatory system which
is continually delivering oxygen right
to the mitochondria deep within cells
cells are tiny things and the membrane
is almost invisibly small if you were to
iron out the membranes in the
mitochondria in our own body you'd get
about four football pitches worth of
membranes and all those membranes have
got a charge across it
which if you were to shrink yourself
down to the size of a molecule
is equivalent to a bolt of lightning
that's what's animating us
we're basically powered by electricity
we would not be moving at all if it
wasn't for energy flow
that gives you different insights genes
work in a specific environment that
environment is cells
cells have a particular structure and
that structure conditions what the genes
can and cannot do and so when we bring
energy into it we begin to understand
this peculiar trajectory of life on
earth
this is one thing in biochemistry which
is really striking
the way that plant cells work the way
the bacteria work
the way that animals work
it's all the same
there is a commonality
that gives me a very strong fellow
feeling with the rest of life
this deep similarity in everything
then we'll have this amazing variation
it's astonishing that you can use these
building blocks to come up with the
world which is so different
that is the glory of evolution
[Music]
you